uh he's so fast in those first two
rounds and I think he's the fastest in
the whole division in those first two
rounds I think the most dangerous too as
far as putting your lights out with
speed yeah that that's the X Factor
there if if he can't stop that though
kind of the grappling Onslaught
it just the more time that that Alex is
spending in the middle of that Octon the
more chances he has of getting knocked
out exactly and if volcanovski gets him
down early
it's the opposite exactly it goes the
other way yep you take away his early
speed you take away his early finish
power energy and now in the third fourth
fifth round you have a much easier to
deal with Rodriguez if you look in the
in the results this isn't a fact this is
if you look at past habits past results
that's what you'd be looking at on the
film yep it doesn't mean that's the
Rodriguez we're gonna see though